we grow up in cultures with narratives
that tell us who we are by ways of
simplification and this is happening
everywhere so I am being told that if
you are coming from a Muslim geography
you are a Muslim and you can be nothing
else or this has to be your primary
identity if you if you if you go
elsewhere
you know you will you will come across
the same narrative across Europe from
the far right you if you are a Christian
or if you are a Dutch just be that you
know and nothing else
all the extremist ideologies what they
have in common is they simplify
complexity yeah and they based on
identity politics and all identity
politics is based on exclusion that's
why I have a huge problem with all kinds
of organized religions because they're
based on a distinction between us versus
them and this the the the presumption
that us is better than them you know
sometimes expressed sometimes not
expressed so I do agree that we
intellectuals or or all the left the
Liberals have not done a very good job
in terms of connecting with people's
anxieties and we must be critical of
that but at the same time we have to see
we have to resist this tendency to
simplify things because as human beings
we are so complex we are composed of
multiple selves you know we're made of
water
our main element is water yeah it's
based on flow what do I mean is I yes
I'm an Istanbul light I'm at the same
time a Londoner I have connections to
the Balkans I have connections to the
Middle East there is in me so many
elements from the Middle East you know
at the same time I'm a European by
choice at the same time on a world
citizen at the same time I'm a global
soul so if I can have multiple multiple
belongings there's a bigger chance that
my multiple belongings will converge
with yours but if I am based defined on
the basis of a single exclusivist
identity politics there is no way we can
find common ground we need to abolish
that narrative that tells us you can
only be one thing you can only you know
simplify the the narrative and for that
we need intellectuals we need you to go
back to humanism we need to go back to
the basics but revolutionize
radicalize it we can't have a more
radical humanism and I know I spoke you
know I'm taking your time but if I may
add this we need to also talk about
certain subjects that we have abundant
for too long and faith is one of them I
think faith is a subject that's too
important to abandon to the religious
you know and faith is not necessarily a
religious concept when you start writing
a book it's an act of faith when you
fall in love it's an act of faith when
you move to a new city it's an act of
faith there are so many moments in our
lives that are acts of faith that have
nothing to do with religion and we also
need doubt because faith without doubt
will turn into dogma so we need the
vaults we need the dance the dialectics
of faith and up these are also issues
that we don't talk about and if we don't
talk about these things people go to the
far right people go to the religious
because the reason need to talk about
these issues we are being pulled in two
very opposite directions and the second
trend is gaining speed right now yes on
the one hand we had high hopes you know
about world citizens global Souls
internationalism multiculturalism which
is not a favorable world anymore and
then the other one the tribalism
isolationism the illusion that sameness
will bring safety this is what we are
being spoon-fed right now they are
telling us if you are being surrounded
by people who are exactly like you who
dress up like you speak like you who
come from the same background you'll be
safe it's an illusion we are far too
globalized to have this whether we have
walls actual physical walls or not
sameness will not bring us safety